[Music]
where was your head at where was your
heart at going into this kind of like
exhausted on love and like i needed like
a break from it i was just like this is
no fun anymore like i need a hot minute
you plan this in the end
it's over
let's just face it love's not easy it's
a lot of work it's hard it can hurt you
know it has its ups and downs so in a
very playful
way with a sense of humor i kind of
wrote an album about that and in doing
so avril was able to reflect on her past
relationships while also starting
something new with one of her
collaborators matsun i've been lucky to
experience some great loves in my life
and you know
sometimes
i don't know maybe it's like a season
thing this person is around for this
song whatever the album is called love
sucks but the song that i wrote also
called love sucks literally the lyric in
the chorus it's like oh
not another breakup like nah nah not
another breakup but at the same time
like literally two days later like i
started dating somebody i had a new
boyfriend i like to be in a relationship
i do love love
now the couple is gearing up for their
canadian tour in support of avril's new
album you are going on the road and
modsun's going on the road with you we
know you're great together we know that
you can hang out together can you tour
together he actually went on tour last
fall and i joined him and we had a song
called flames
together
i joined him for a few dates it was
super fun and just jumped up on stage
and we'd sing mad and i was there
actually just like supporting him while
he was on his tourette